foreign
this is five questions to ask before
buying we'll put a link to this in the
show notes and also in here you can find
the these five questions on our website
if you go to the minimalists.com
wallpaper you can have them on your
phone so whether you're at the store or
getting ready to shop online you can
have it as a desktop wallpaper as well
you can download these five questions
and there's a nice little reminder
before you decide to buy something new
the first question to ask yourself if
you're getting ready to buy something
new is can I afford to part with this
money here's a hint if you have to
charge it to a credit card you can't
afford it amen now that is not an insult
there are many things that I can't
afford because I simply don't have the
cash for it yeah now why don't I want to
go into debt for those things because
maybe I feel like I really want it now
or maybe I feel like I even need it
right now well the truth is I don't want
to punish My Future Self for my current
in impulses I don't want to punish My
Future Self I don't want to borrow from
my future in order to placate myself
right now yeah the second question to
ask is can I pay the actual cost yeah
Ryan you would talk about the true cost
of an item oh sure I mean there's the
cost of storing the thing maintaining
the thing watering the thing charging
the thing changing the batteries and the
thing yes changing the oil and the thing
refueling the thing repainting the thing
taking care of the thing protecting the
thing yeah there's so many other costs
that like we just don't ever think about
yeah and so it goes beyond the price tag
right we pay for an item then we end up
paying for it over and over again the
storing of the thing the worrying about
the thing the psychological and
emotional costs of our thing are
immeasurable so we have to choose really
carefully what things we bring into our
lives because we can't afford every
thing yeah I mean it's really easy to
look at the price and say yeah I can
afford that that's quantifiable but like
all those other costs that I mentioned
like that's those are the emotional and
the psychological costs like those are
really difficult to quantify so yeah
we've got to be real careful yeah number
three
will it add value to my life
so for me it must serve a purpose if I
buy something that's going to serve a
purpose or it's going to amplify or
enhance my experience of life and if not
I have to be honest with myself and I
have to leave it on the Shelf yeah
because if it's not going to add value
to my life
for an extended period of time
then it's
leaving it at the store
is like letting go in advance yeah tweet
that
tweet that Professor Sean
hey uh I really like the joy does it
bring joy it was an or server purpose is
that what yeah that article was saying
oh the article earlier was talking about
whether or not it is it is it's either
useful or it's beautiful yeah useful or
beautiful that's what it is I love that
that's uh and you're both Ryan oh thanks
man
here's the next question for you
question four
what are the alternatives
in other words what is is this the best
use of this money right so say I do want
to buy a 100 widget because you know me
I love some widgets you love widgets I
have so many widgets 13 of them
um anyway I have a whole widget
collection no if I'm getting ready to
buy something and it's 100 bucks and
let's say it is going to add value to my
life that's not a good enough reason to
buy it though if it's useful or
beautiful great that's one of the
questions but it's not the only question
that I'm asking here because if I have a
hundred dollars that is a finite
resource yeah is this the best use of
this money and if not I'd rather spend
that hundred dollars elsewhere yeah it's
that old Andy Davis line that we love he
has that great song called Good Life and
he said we struggle to pay rent because
jeans are expensive yeah and that
perfectly
summarizes our obsession with
consumerism we're forsaking our needs in
order to get what we want right now yeah
and the fifth and final question to ask
before buying something is
can I get by without it for a while now
it doesn't mean you have to live without
it forever right we have something in
our minimalist rule book over at the
minimalists.com rulebook you can
download it for free of the 16 rules
that are in there there's one that we
call the wait for it rule or the 30 30
rule yeah and that basically says hey if
something costs more than thirty dollars
I wait 30 hours to buy it now it doesn't
mean that I can't afford it I have
thirty dollars in my pocket I could buy
it right now right why do I wait then
well I wait because maybe if I think
about it for a day I'll realize that
that was just an Impulse yeah and maybe
I'll be just fine or even better without
it yeah amen
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcasts available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free